don't know my mind
48 and i think she's moved to think 72
now i've sent
okay uh welcome everyone to this
afternoon's general licensing
subcommittee meeting uh before we start
i would just like to confirm
the subcommittee members who are in
attendance today um
they are uh councillor michelle emmons
councillor anthony hutchinson
councillor pat kerry councillor heather
liggett and councillor stephen pickering
my name's alan mar and i'm the clerk to
the committee uh there's also kevin
roland
licensing team leader shannon smith
licensing officer
kevin shilato a solicitor who will be
the
panels or rather the subcommittee's
legal advisor today
and damon stanton from the government
service who will be here
as facilitator for the meeting
now the first order of business today
members at item one is the appointment
of a chair
so could i ask members to nominate a
chair for today's meeting
could i propose uh councillor
council etiquette it's been proposed
that we have a second remember
uh yes that's councillor emin sorry i
couldn't see you there for the moment
uh so councillor evans is seconded to
our members content with that
yes members have indicated our content
so uh from that point of view councillor
liggett uh
can you take the chair thank you thank
you colleagues can we move to item two
on the
agenda declarations of interest members
are requested to declare the existence
and nature of any disposable
coonery interests and or other any other
interests
not already on their register of
interest in any item on the agenda and
withdrawn from the meeting
withdrawal from the meeting at the
appropriate time do we have any
declarations
uh none have been received chair thank
you
we have a protocol in place for these
virtual meetings of the subcommittee
which is set out in the agenda i would
like the clock to briefly explain it
yes thank you jeff as well commemorate
uh still hear me
yes yes okay thanks uh just to confirm
that this virtual meeting will follow
the format that has now become well
established within the council
uh first of all i'd be grateful if
members could keep their cameras on
uh at all times and remain on camera
throughout the meeting
could you also observe the rules of
procedure and of course the virtual
standing orders
at all times in terms of the
practicalities
could you keep your microphone muted
unless you wish to speak
and then please raise your hand or write
speak in the chat function
the first part of the meeting is being
live streamed from the council's website
this will continue until you resolve to
exclude the public
i would be grateful therefore if you
could make if you could not make any
reference to the main business or any of
the people involved in the main business
until then in terms of the procedure for
the hearing itself
um it will very much follow the
lines that would actually happen as if
they were taking place in the council
chamber especially in terms of hearing
the representations
we've had to put it there at uh item
three on the agenda
uh i think it's fairly straightforward
so if members have no questions on it
i will then hand back to the chair so
anything there members that
you need clarification on
uh no one's indicated chair so uh thank
you
okay thank you uh item four uh thanks
for that we have no urgent business
so we can move straight to the next item
the exclusion of the public
uh that the public be excluded from the
meeting during the discussion of the
forthcoming
item of business to afford to avoid the
disclosure
to them of exempt information as defined
in paragraph 1
part 1 of the schedule 12a to the local
government act 1972
as amended by the local government
access to information
variation order 2006.
is that okay with everybody
thank you thank you colleagues now we
have we are in private session
we
you